okay cool
thanks uh let's get this started so as
you can see
the name of my talk is actually was
getting started with 3gs in webgl
but i had this thought are you familiar
with this drawing
so i have this impression that
everything that's kind of getting
started it's like okay i've
done i've got a spinning cube what do i
do now
so it's gonna be actually like okay
getting things done with 3js and webgl
and hopefully
we can get to to that so we're gonna do
some unit testing first to check that
the
the talk is actually working so i'm here
yes i am
uh the audience is here okay so checks
out
uh this is my cat's contribution
so it's it's an iron cut
[Music]
so yeah this is webgl so so
we're done that's it that's what gl
that's got so
it's it can't get any better
[Music]
it can't get any better than this so
so yeah uh as karina said i work for
vril uh
we're a production company uh creative
and partners that
we've done several things um on the
internet like the
first webgl game that was for google
maps or the wilderness downtown
the first html5 uh video clip for arcade
fire
or the gravity website
so yeah with this kind of cool things
so if you're interested in creative
career
ask me and on my personal time i do all
this kind of explorations on
on graphics and everything that can run
on the
on the web because i'm really fascinated
by the web platform and javascript i
love it
and this part of many of my of my
experiments
so how do you get to to build uh 3d
experiences what
what do we understand as as building 3d
experiences
so i'm going to show you something that
um i've been working um
lately i finished a few months ago um
i'm going to play it
it's um this
it's a little bit blurry
let me try again with the high quality
setting directly
[Music]
[Laughter]
so this is running on the browser it's
using webgl um
and like you can actually go
in interactive and and look around this
all being rendered in real time on your
browser
so it's it's pretty it's very powerful
so it
might look like a video but it's
actually uh running on real time it's
making use of of of a of a web api
you can see it here that it's actually
running on a browser it's not a video
it's interactive
so how do you get to to to bus to build
something
like this so we're using webgl webgl
it's a
it's a web api it's um
controlled by the chronos group you can
get these links here
to check you've got all the
documentation on the
mozilla developer network or on the
microsoft developer network
but there are many samples and there's
many chrome experiments
and basically it's an api it's a
javascript api that allows us to
to harness the the power of the gpus
that are running on our systems
it's based on opengl es which is the one
that runs on
on on your mobile devices not the one
on desktops so it's a bit uh limited
regarding of the current
state-of-the-art opengl
but it gets a lot of things done so it's
it's really it's really useful
so the thing with webgl is that um
a demo like this is one of the san
angelos observatory
one of the classic sample demos um
if you check the code it's a crazy
amount of of
code binding buffers getting data from
one end to the other because
everything that that's on your main cpu
memory has to be transferred to the gpu
memory so it works
much faster so it's it's it gets pretty
verbose and very pretty complicated
so we have 3js it's a
higher level javascript api it it's a
layer of abstraction on top of all these
uh
elements that you have for webgl uh
again 3js.org it's the main site for the
project you've got the
github page with everything there's
examples there's a documentation there's
even a start
a getting started guide with everything
that you need so
it's designed for it's it's
conceptualized for for beginners
so it's for people that want to get do
cool things on on
on the browser without actually lots of
3d algebra and knowledge
and it really works for that purpose
so how do you study so you have to set
up you've seen
a bit of this before the on the on the
previous talk with
about the web by webvr so basically your
code structure is you
utilize your renderer then you set up
your scene and then you just
run through the animation loop that's
basically everything you have to do
so this would be the code you've seen
something similar before
you include the library and then you
create a renderer
use this is a new thing you set the
pixel ratio because now we're dealing
with a
retina displays high device density
screens you set the size because you
want to cover the whole screen or power
of the screen
attach it to your dom create a scene
a scene sorry it's a it's a container
for everything that we want to draw
so that scene it's basically a structure
so we can do a few
optimizations uh it basically holds
everything in our world
and when you put a camera on it then we
can discriminate what's going to be
drawn depending on what the camera is
looking so everything that for instance
uh behind us it doesn't get computed so
it's kind of this
uh optimizations uh then we create a
camera based on an aspect ratio
it's more or less modeling a real little
camera so you've got the
the size the field of view the distance
that you want to
to look at and set the render loop
basically with request animation frame
and call the renderer with our scene and
our camera
you can have many scenes you can have
many cameras and you can kind of
combine them to get a more complex uh
rendering
experience so what do we do with the
scene we need to
add some stuff to render stuff it's
really it's
usually objects we call them meshes
unless it's a
it's a combination of a geometry and a
material
so we basically create it with the three
mesh object we provide the geometry we
provide the material
add it to the scene and then we can
render it
so how do we choose a geometry so
there's a few three js primitives
there's sphere boxes cylinders towards
geometry
and it's basically like this so you can
you can create it
um keep in mind this representation this
is like the most basic material you can
use it's a wireframe
mesh but all these different points
connected by lines are going to be
important
later so how do you use this
you can basically create a material and
then for instance a cube
it's a new three match with a box
geometry specifying the size
with height depth added to the scene
you can create a sphere for instance
equals a human geometry
it's all pretty pretty much the same
thing you create a geometry
with your parameters you place it on the
world you add it to your scene
the render is going to take care of that
so
another way of providing a geometry
besides this
constructors this this console that come
by default
it's loading models loving objects that
are created with
a maya 3d studio in many different
formats
so for instance this is edward snowden
um
sculpture the one that was retired it
was forbidden to
to be on on greenpack i think it was um
and someone posted the the stl file on
on the internet so you can use it and
basically you can load it really easily
so
loading a model same thing it's it's
basically
you instantiate an object loader or an
st loader depending on the format that
you're going to
be using uh provide the the the file you
want to
load and you've got a an asynchronous
callback with the geometry so again you
create your mesh with a geometry
material put it on your scene it's it's
to get taken care of
so once you have something running on on
on your
on your you've got a geometry you've got
a mesh
uh you have to choose how to lead it
because there's that's how things look
more realistic
so there's uh the light mode that's
basically what defines how a material is
going to look
so basically um there's flat there's a
very basic lumbering phone
um let's get back to this one and what
we're going to do is this is
called a mesh normal material it
shows what's the normal direction of
each surface
basically the normal it's the direction
in which a face is looking so this
face is looking up this face is looking
down it's just for illumination so
you know the surface type is looking up
it's going to be lit by the slides and
when it's looking down it's not going to
be as much late so we use that for
calculations
so um for instance
if we do um we have a function
uh called uh create font material
uh can i do this cool so
this this function basically can you
read correctly
like this okay so this creates a
mesh foam material and the constructor
has a few variables like you can specify
a color but you want the surface to be
you can specify normal map which defines
like the the the
details of the surface and a few other
things so
if i take my snow then model and i say
that the material
which is part of my mesh it's uh
this create foam material we're going to
get this
this different i actually need to tell
the geometry
that the normals need update small
detail
so now we have this um and then we have
a
certain number of lights we have an
ambient light that defines like the
global term like how it looks um right
now the
light it's got a color it's this kind of
gray but i could set
an rgb so it's uh let's say just a bit
red
so that's what defines the whole the
whole color and i also have an overhead
uh
white light um which you can see here
um and i can do all kinds of things with
these materials these are the default
materials that you can play with them
uh for instance if i take my snow then
that material
it's got i don't know like shininess uh
right now it's a value of 30 but if i
put it to 100
it's way shinier you can see that it
looks more like plastic
if i crank it up to 500 likes
really porcelain looking so that's
basically the the values that you're
going to be playing with you can you can
you can do lots of stuff with this
so how do you add all these things
together so then
when we have chosen one of our uh
light model materials like lambert or
phone material we have to
to add some lights so we have also 3js
has a lot of different lights
we have an ambient light which is the
fuse term we have the directional lights
same thing just create it specify the
the data
on on the constructor place it on the
scene and add it and the render is going
to take all that exists in the scene
calculate correctly and render to a
stream so
there's also a spotlight which behaves
more like this
this kind of light cannons um
some of the lights with some of the
materials can have shadow like cast
shadows
so you have to play with all this um
that's what it comes with uh by default
but
there's other kind of uh lightning
models that you can use
like for instance this is spherical
environment mapping
this one it's much better it's using a
circular texture and what it does is
creates a much
nicer lighting just by using a
texture actually so the texture is
something like
this let me see one second it's this one
so this is the texture your you're using
and you can replace it so it's much
easier to define
a lining model with photoshop and then
bring it into your synthetic
having all the calculations so there's
another one which is the
image based lighting this one uses an
environment
like a cube map or a rectangular
panorama like street view and then you
get like
much much nicer it's a bit dark actually
but you get much nicer
materials you can see that this one has
all these
much nicer reflections on the back
and lights and if you just change the
the surroundings it just goes um
it looks uh as it as if it was there
so um another way of
choosing a lightning model is just not
caring about lighting models and using
base textures
so in the in the in the demo and crossy
form that you've seen before
this is actually the the wall lights
it's it's just a big texture a big dark
texture actually
but like for instance that's the that's
the ground and that's the
the sides of the of the wall that's the
the lights from the ceiling
so basically you texture all these
lights and you don't have to worry
because mostly like the diffuse term in
a in a in an environment it doesn't
change it doesn't change with your view
what changes is this specular term
and that's the thing that you have to
care when you uh want to to code it
so basically that's that's that's what
you have like everything it's
all these light models are actually
running on on shaders are running on the
gpu
so shaders uh it's it's more like a
more complicated concept for this talk
but i'm trying to i'll try to explain it
basically as either it's a program that
tells the system how to draw something
on screen
so we have two kinds of uh of shaders we
have um
vertex shaders and we have sorghum
second
okay
we have vertex shaders and we have
fragment shaders um
the vertex shader defines how a geometry
has to be
transformed like how something all the
spawns that we've seen
go into screen and a fragment share
defines how things are
drawn like what color goes into its
pixels so you can for instance
um let's see which program is this one
yeah so let's let's say that we have
this scene here and
we want to see just the second okay
much better so okay
so like this is this is our um
this is our fragment shader and then
this is what it's not entirely
javascript this is just glsl so
that's something that you provide to the
to the to the material and you have to
code it's kind of a c
uh dialect so for instance um we can do
like let's make the the color it's just
um
an orange color okay
back three okay sorry so this is kind of
like coding so i've just turned
everything into
into a purple color uh i could use for
instance just the diffuse
like the uh diffuse texture is it
diffuse no yeah so this is just the flat
you see this is the flat image i can
check the
specular for instance so these are
all textures that i've uploaded i've
specified to the material and then
in the fragment shader i define how i
want them to to
to play i can use for instance the the
environment mapping
which is like this so everything looks
like like it's
a mirror
and basically what you're doing on the
fragment shader is just take all these
different
textures different computer values and
turn them into a texture that looks
right on screen
okay
so there's been lots of talks about
shader toy so if you haven't seen it
it's a
it's placed with that it's a
[Music]
website that you can use to
code your shaders running them on the
browser everything is running on
just two triangles so it's it's it's
pretty amazing
you can do let me see one thing
this for instance this one
so this one is creating a sea
landscape and it's playing music uh
using the gpu and basically all this
scene that you're seeing
there's literally no textures there's no
moon for instance that's no moon
and everything has been rendered on with
this equation
everything is a mathematical equation
and it's being rendered for each
pixel on screen so it's pixel defines
how it looks in that scene with the
reflection with water
with the sky the the clouds everything
it's
pretty awesome so check it out
shadertoy.com
so once you have we have everything we
have our
objects our meshes with our materials
our lights everything
how we do get to animate that so
everything is a 3d object that's kind of
the prototype of everything on 3js
can be translated can be rotated can be
can be scaled
um okay and what you do basically it's
in your code in your javascript code
just take a cube set position
it's three values in 3d xyz you can
direction you can address one of the
components
you can change the rotation you can set
the whole rotation
you can move the camera to a specific
point
a long time you can create a new
position and make the camera look at
that position so
that's how you're going to be moving
everything and telling how things
move you would be using probably an
animation library you'll be using a
tweening library or
reading from some from some
[Music]
scene file telling you how the camera
moves how thing everything
moves or you would be using uh controls
like you've seen on the webvr
there's a long set of different controls
that
connect the input with the camera in the
scene
there's the traditional orbit controls
in which you kind of rotate around an
object in
in your in your scene or there's the vr
controls which connect with a
with a vr hmd there's device orientation
controls in case you're
developing for for cardboard so it uses
the the accelerometer on your phone
and basically on your render loop just
use controls update and then the camera
would be
on the right orientation
good so when you're doing all this
the things that it's difficult to to get
right because this is basically
something that
i kind of advise to discover as an
as a as a hobby that's not like um get
into game development like
like crazy so when you're exploring this
um it's okay to not go
straight for something that you want to
do it's okay to to kind of digress it's
great to
procrastinate because usually you get
things out of procrastinating
at least in my case so for instance um
while doing that demo
um i was researching the parallax
corrected reflection mapping which is
what makes the
the walls look kind of glossy and
everything's corrected
but then i wanted to investigate a bit
more about materials so i
went for a long hike trying to
understand materials with the physical
base rendering so it was for a long time
doing uh weird things um like trying to
replicate the
the bulls so that's the real one that's
the webgl one
still far from perfect but weird things
that happen then you start doing
more things more materials you get into
into crazy stuff like
like placing faces on your geometry
what is this i don't know so
so also like trying to get this for the
camera work
i came up with a library that it's like
a storyboard there's lots of solutions
for timelines but for instance i came
with this one that it's something that
you can define on with the json
and just with like regular human
language you can define all the
animation for this
this on a github of course it's it's
pretty useful if someone wants to build
like a timeline editor on top of that
i'd be perfectly okay with that um
another thing that you get uh by the end
when everything's it's running it's post
processing that's a really important
part of what we
what we consider the the final cgi
uh look um i've been working on a
library for post processing for three as
it's called wagner
3gs has its own post processing system
but i don't really like it i don't think
it's it's
clear enough so i came up with with with
a
simpler one um this for instance the
scene running with the
with the with the post processing it's
got all the all the
depth of field it's got uh lights it's
got
a bit of dirty on the lens like all the
cool stuff that they are doing on the
games
and it's pretty use it's pretty easy to
use so you basically uh
include the the the files and create a
composer that's depending on on your
renderer
set set the size that you want to have
so it has to match the size of your
renderer
and basically instead of calling render
renders in you just
reset the composer tell the composer to
render that scene so it holds it on a
frame buffer
and then you put it on screen that's the
most basic doing that
would basically do the same as rendering
a scene so
that's the funny thing so this would be
like your scene this got nothing
on it then you create a cga pass for
instance to simulate the cga display
and on your render you do the composer
reset render
then execute the pass that's going to do
this cga look
and then the screen so what you get is
something like this so
you're processing the all the other
pixels on your on your buffer to look
like a like an old
cga for four colors uh display
so um most passes that you can never go
wrong with
it's depth of field that looks really
nice
don't overdo it that's the secret for
everything a bloom which makes
things kind of glare like things that
look um
very bright chromatic aberration it's
something that photographs or
cinematographers try to
get away with get away from but in cji
we
just do flares and chromatic
aberrational things that shouldn't be
done tone mapping it's it's super nice
so you get the exact tone that you want
everyone is doing it on movies on tv
shows uh a vignette which makes like
this sense of of
the borders are darker no it's it's
interesting that we want to have the
best looking cgi image but actually
adding noise
makes it more real in our eyes so
basically the secret is not to know over
not overdo it
um like everything has to be subtle so
we know as developers that when we have
something we want to show it
but like subtlety it's it's the key in
with with this kind of effects
so when you're doing all this it's
difficult to actually like
how to develop how you optimize all this
um there's this one library
i made because if you're working with
shaders and usually
um second so
basically if you've got uh an error like
let's play again you're gonna okay
what's this okay wait wait wait
ah what where man oh
no this okay it couldn't compile
so it's it's pretty like every time you
break the shader it's it's something
like this it's pretty
pretty annoying to to to find so this
library i made
uh that you can start with npm it's
called maintenance compilers compile
shader
what it does it takes the webgl compile
shader which takes this source code and
validates it and in case there's
something wrong
what it does is basically put this on
screen which is much easier for you to
see okay i
screw up with the there's no precision
specified for float so
go back to the code it's it's it's a
kind of nice uh
library um based on the same concept of
of
augmenting the the
the prototypes or taking objects from
native browser and turn it into
something
much better there's this other library i
did
usually when you have something
on 3js like let's say you've got the
cube
and you check on the console you see
this kind of structures
and you open it it's it's it's kind of
weird and the matrix
it's got elements uh okay you know how
to read that
so basically what i do is i trap
console.log and if i recognize
some of the uh the type of the objects
that
are gonna that are being passed what i
do is use a different
um a different rendering system
like for instance in this case i'm using
a table so you can actually
uh format much correctly everything that
you want to
debug so if you have any object that you
know how should be structured on the
console
with that system which is hooking into
console.log and modifying it
the output depending on your inputs you
can do things like that or
you can do even things like uh let's say
that you want to see
how's the materials so so yeah you can
render
uh graphics on the console so that's
pretty cool yeah it's pretty fun because
you can you can start
doing lots of things you can do an
animated gif so you can now put an
animated gif out of your
console log um cool
so another thing there's the you've
probably seen it there's the webgl
shader editor uh this is something also
i've been working
it's uh i mean it's basically it's um
there's already a shader editor for
firefox this one's for for chrome
so basically you can you can uh play
with it check everything
see what's this okay i'm gonna modify
this this and i'm gonna come
to the vertex shader and i'm gonna say
like um
so the position of my vertex
it's gonna be uh like this
cool okay this one is and then post dot
i know that it's gonna be
multiplied by the sinus of the
y so okay i don't know what i did so
time zero let's see oh this is a lot
okay
let's see okay okay just completely
completely destroyed uh it won't snow
then
uh let's say 0.5 something better okay
this is this
let's just see i mean but it's cool
because then you can play with your with
with everything on on the browser
it's a much much faster uh process
and then of course you can also uh
modify your your shaders here and
and same thing modify everything it's
it's a pretty cool uh process
it's very difficult to debug on the
actual gpu code so that's the best
that you can you can kind of get um
ok
[Music]
what
okay there we go okay so that's it so
releasing once you've got all this done
so there's a few considerations
before doing that there's there's many
platforms so webgl is now pretty
standardized but it's running on on on
desktop it's running on laptops it's
running on on mobile phones on
on ios 8 now so you have to consider for
that you have to consider for instance
windows has a different
kind of a bit more stickler
implementation of of webgl
there's retina displays which are
massive considering the number of pixels
that you're drawing
so usually you might have to consider
that you have to downsize your textures
you might have to simplify models making
them lower resolution
you may have to to scale down the actual
render
and then stretch it back or you can you
might have to reduce
completely or just modify the post
processing all these kinds are kind of
intensive
uh use a cdn like cloudflare because
usually when we're doing all these
things there's like models and textures
are pretty big
uh but if you're at that point releasing
something congratulations that's the
that's the whole thing
everything that is really is a good
release and i've got time for lessons
learned
um really early release often it's
pretty much uh
um everyone says the same but if you're
trying to do something out of a hobby
um don't obsess like it's not gonna be
perfect so go for whatever you think it
can be done
if you're hitting a wall
worry about it for a while do something
go do something else
remember there's creation through
procrastination or it's also called yak
shaving
but you can come back at a later time
and you might have learned a new thing
that
unlocks that thing that you wanted to do
and slowly you will be able to be doing
anything you want like medical
visualizations or games or
webvr so again
all this has to be iterated and iterated
and then iterated again
try to block as soon as possible try to
place every object
like as many things on your scene that's
super important for webvr
but um basically try to get everything
there and then refine
so it's a bit like like the progressive
enhancement you have to
first know what's your scene gonna
contain and then build from that
um it could be using for that keep the
music for last if you're using music
because you're gonna hear it a thousand
times
you're gonna end up hating it or even
better try to use a different music
for the final release and do what i call
the performance driven development
which is basically every change you do
make sure it works on all your target
platforms
before going uh on for a while because
maybe you got to a point in which you
cannot go back
uh trying to improve the performance
it's not like something that
if it's going slow on a different
platform it's not like something easy to
fix it's probably gonna
give you a lot of of misery um and
as long as it works it's fine i mean
that's that's the trick it's uh it
doesn't have to be technical perfect
doesn't
have to be mathematically correct it has
to work it has to look nice
so that's me i was thinking the director
of creative technologies at b real i've
got my website pictorials.com
i'm going to show you some things that
also can be done like shiny spheres that
bounce around or um
spheres that follow each other in kind
of a popcorn
dance i don't know that's what your
imagination can
can come up to create you can add
physics you can add all kinds of
behaviors to your javascript code
and that's it thanks
[Applause]
so talking about questions
um okay
where do you get your models and
animations from do you have
modeler on your team or have sites to
recommend
so yeah there's i mean usually it's a
good thing to find some friend
or a colleague that does a 3d modeling
or it's got some
some jobs on on 3d studio there's
there's plenty of people willing to to
get their
their models out there the things that
they usually what they do it's just the
model not the uv mapping which is the
hard part
so uh you cannot texture texture them
correctly but
um there's there's plenty of them there
there's um
blendswap.com for for
getting models uh yeah there's there's a
bunch depends on on exactly if you're
looking for something that's got a
license or
that it's free so it can be kind of
cheapish but it's free um but i would
advise trying to find someone that is
willing to
to go into a a tighter loop of
let's do this and we'll get something
out there it's cool
what is the status of ray tracing or
particle systems in webgl and 3gs
so ray tracy i mean ray tracing is
something that
won't work on on on gpus i mean it can
be
optimized and it can be done really well
but it's like the
the pure nature of the ray tracing that
recursivity of the algorithm
doesn't play well with gpus uh that
basically try to run everything
uh in parallel but in a linear fashion
but there's there's there's lots of
efforts there's also i mean you don't
actually have to go all forward matching
the ray tracing there's ray marching
most of the shader toy demos are done
with ray marching which works much
better with
it's a similar technique but it works
much better with gpus
uh in particle system basically since we
have gpu particles uh i mean you can
have
a few million particles uh running
with no problem depends on what's the
actual um movement
they want them to have there's like
everyone's doing curly noise so all
these particles that go like like
like like this kind of wavy motion if
you want them to do something more
complicated like physical simulation
it's it's gonna produce you can probably
go to 64
000 particles which is kind of enough
so something more general but i think
it's still a good question any
recommendation
how to start yeah basically i mean
there's there's the the 3cs.org
website there's there's a getting
started there there's a ton of examples
and those are like the unit tests of the
of the build
so that's that's what it's used to check
that everything it's it's working
of course it's difficult to unit test
graphics so so basically it has to be
done on
on a visual examination
aspect but yeah there's there's a
very big community community you can ask
on stack overflow
and so yeah mostly
it's it's like if you if you are trying
to do something
and and it makes sense you will find the
solution right away if you don't find it
it's probably because you're not asking
the right thing you're
you're you've gotten mixed up concepts
so some someone will probably
address you in the right direction um
you recommend to use the cdnophobic
objects
what about versioning it is said to be
sad for those
um like versioning
yeah those are really big files
and some are text based so it can be
they can be versions some are binary
based
so it depends like github now has a
github is aware of stl files so they
probably have a different path
for those but
it's difficult basically it's out of
space
that's why you're advised to use a cdn
or some caching uh
in front of your page because you you
might kill
your server how about performance on
mobile
um so everything i've i've shown works
on works on on my nexus 5 and
it's it's pretty it's pretty performant
like uh
an ios implement i say implementations
are even faster so
if you're aware of the limitations uh
which are not usually
worrying like um you you have enough
performance but
mostly what you want to do on on on the
platform
so so yeah i mean it's it's pretty it's
pretty stable
it's pretty stable pretty fast and let
me see one second so
let's see if i have
hello god send me a signal
yeah no okay but i can show you
uh afterwards it's um
okay it it works it's it's really good
like you should try also mobile uh
webgl and like cardboard it's using
mobile webgl so
so it's a really nice way of getting
into um
mobile web vr any questions from the
audience
of course there are can i get a mic over
there
sure
um just a little questions what's your
workflow when you have to when you have
like already um
3d composition with all the lights
saying mesh and material
set in like let's say blender or 3ds max
and
then you kind of export it all to and
then play with it in
a browser or is you follow a different
path
this is more i guess related to
further referencing the objects on the
scene with the javascript to provide
some
additional interactions i guess so
just wonder what's what's your way of
doing that definitely
um so offering offering the assets it's
it's it's
pretty important on this process so
there's there's a few ways if you
using maya or using 3d studio usually
it's exported
and there's a native importers like the
object loader for 3js
or if you're using blender there's an
exporter for blender
but most of the time there's the the
loop in which uh
3d artists work then you get that and
sometimes
or most of the times there's a free step
you're optimizing your
your meshes uh for your for your
renderer but it's it's pretty it's
pretty fast and of course you can do it
with with with no you can do your
execute your your script and adapt
everything so the
the loop it's pretty it's pretty fast
and then of course you can then
upload update and the designer can see
it so it's it's a very fluid uh
process much faster than most of the of
the native tools actually
okay one more
can't see anyone no more questions okay
there's one over there
hello uh are you enjoying playing games
or
always looking at the meshes and styles
how
they are made
it's they've asked me sometimes if i'm
aware that i'm building like a game
engine
um like that that's one of the things
like uh
everyone's asking about unity and and
and unreal engine
those are like of course a super
powerful engines and they do amazing
things
but mostly first um
our game engine so everything looks kind
of gaming and every
like every unity application looks like
unity made and every unreal engine looks
unreal engine made
um and it takes a bit from from from
actually doing something on your own
even though you can code all the shaders
so
so it's not about so for production of
course uh everyone should go with
with one of these big tools that do a
lot of things
but yeah there's there's this um there's
this cross
contamination of the gaming and the and
the real time uh
graphics um i i don't really
i mean i i play games but i really like
more the
the artistic part of just creating a
demo that plays by itself and
it's not interactive i don't know if
that's what you were asking
awesome well we'll have a coffee break
right now
thank you so much for blowing our minds
you